[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
the painful decisions we've been
softened up for are coming fast now just
11 days until the chancellor sets out
big tax Rises and spending cuts and
possible options are floating everywhere
here in Westminster from roading
pensions to cutting infrastructure
projects meanwhile the PM's promise of a
government of Integrity is under threat
again with allegedly bullying messages
sent by Minister Gavin Williamson
apparently he wasn't happy about not
being invited to the Queen's funeral but
it's the future of the world rather than
the government that Richie sunac will
try and focus on as he goes to the
climate change conference in Egypt we'll
try and work out what's likely to happen
here and there with our guests this
morning
so for the government we'll talk to the
chancellor at the Dutch of Lancaster and
cabinet office Minister Oliver Dowden
this cop gets underway we'll talk to the
shadow climate change secretary Labor's
Ed miliband
and we'll get the view from a country
already at risk with the Marshall
Islands climate Envoy Tina stage
we'll have a very moving interview with
Paul blomfield his father took his own
life and now the labor MP is campaigning
for a change in the law on assisted
dying
and we'll be talking to Sana safe she's
the sister of Allah adolfata the British
Egyptian man being held in Egypt Sana is
campaigning for his release and she will
also be traveling to comp later today
[Music]
morning now our first guest helped to
run Rishi sunax leadership campaign he's
a close friend of the prime minister so
no surprises that Oliver Dowden is now
back in cabinet with a critical role
because as Chancellor of the Dashie of
Lancaster he's responsible for
coordinating delivery across government
and he joins us now thank you very much
for being with us this morning
um let's start off with a bit of good
news uh shall we or some would sick news
we're going to get an extra bank holiday
yes it's fantastic news and I think that
the coronation is a mixture of the
Sacred and the solemn it's the crowning
of our new king but also it's a moment
for celebration and just as we did with
the coronation some 70 years ago there's
another opportunity for the nation to
come together whether that's as families
or communities to celebrate our new king
and I think it will be a fantastic
occasion if they cost money they don't
know bank holidays uh well of course
there is some cost associated with it in
terms of
countries and so are not operating but
there's a huge boost for example to
hospitality and tourism but really the
key Point here is that this is our new
king the first time we've had a new king
crown for 70 years and I think most
people up and down the country would
want to take an opportunity to to
celebrate it and I think it's right that
we should have a bank holiday
talk a bit more about what we can expect
from a Russian student Premiership but
before we'll get to that there's a story
in the Sunday newspapers that we do need
to discuss Gavin Williamson at the cabin
office Minister and he's working of
course in your department now he is
being investigated for alleged bullying
and intimidating Behavior towards Wendy
Morton the former Chief web
astonishingly it seems that this was all
about the fact that he hadn't been
invited to the funeral of the queen and
these uh messages that are in the Sunday
Times this morning include him saying
it's disgusting that you're using her
death to punish people he obviously
thought that she wasn't giving him an
invite for political reasons he said
let's see how many more times you is all
over there is a price for everything
what's your reaction text messages
well that these were sent
um In the Heat of the Moment uh
expressing frustration uh it was a
difficult time for the party I think he
now accepts that he shouldn't have done
it and he regrets doing so and I think
that that's right and thankfully we're
in a bit of a better place now as a
party
it sounds a bit threatening there
doesn't it there's a price for
everything what's that supposed to mean
well remember this was uh Gavin
winnerson when he was a backbencher
expressing his frustrations at a
difficult time for the party with the
then Chief whip he regrets the language
that he uses and I don't think he should
have used that that sort of language but
nonetheless that that is in the past now
and now thankfully we're in a better
place as a party it's not very long ago
it's not like it was three years ago it
was just a you know a matter of kind of
weeks ago if you like and also you know
most people would look at this and say
okay everyone gets frustrated at work
most people wouldn't send those kind of
messages to a colleague does Rishi Cena
have confidence in him well he shouldn't
have sent those messages and he says
that he regrets it but of course the the
Prime Minister continues to have
confidence in Gavin Williamson as a
minister Okay so Jake Berry the former
party chair says that he told Rishi
sunak about this complaint the day
before he was appointed to the cabinet
is that true
well I don't think it was any secret
that uh Gavin Williamson and other back
benchers had a difficult relationship
with the chief whip but it's not because
it was he told it
um it is not the case that the Prime
Minister saw this exchange of text
messages and until they were leaked
newspapers last night he was aware of
the allegation well he was aware that
there were there was a difficult
relationship between the chief Whip and
a number of of back benches of which
Gavin Williamson was did he know that
she had accused uh the former Chief
Gavin Williamson of bullying her to know
that allegation well he knew that there
was a difficult relationship between
them now clearly there is a complaints
process which is ongoing at the
conservative party which I'm not part
and I I can't I can't cut across that
individual complaint did he know the
complaint had been made well the the
Prime Minister knew that there was a
difficult uh relationship and I think
because as you see well I think as
you've seen from the the former chairman
Jake Berry uh he says that he
highlighted that to the the Prime
Minister but in terms of these specific
uh allegations this specific exchange
the Prime Minister wasn't aware of it
until last night um I just want to look
at Governor Williamson's career and this
is a man who kept a tarantula in his
desk when he was Chief whip he was fired
as defense secretary by Theresa May for
leaking sensitive National Security
information he was then fired as
education secretary by Boris Johnson
over the exams Fiasco during covid he
was put back in the cabinet by Rishi
sunak and then immediately caught an
alleged bullying scandal you know what
was it about Gavin Williamson's record
in government that made origin sooner
think yes I want that man in my cabinet
well I actually think you can see in the
the government that Richie sunac formed
as prime minister he brought together
people from all across the conservative
party he brought supporters of Liz tras
he brought supportive Boris Johnson he
brought people that supported on him on
his campaign and I think Gavin
Williamson has paid a a big part in the
the conservative party and I think it's
right that he should be as part of that
team that brings together all parts of
the conservative party so it's got
nothing to do with the fact that he
played an instrumental role in Rishi
Cena's campaign to become Prime Minister
well I think you can see in the the
government that Rishi soon informed that
he was bringing together all different
parts of the conservative party and
Gavin forms part of that okay
now let's move on shall we you are
incredibly close to the prime minister
of course I know you're going to be
plugged into what we can expect from
origin Scenic Premiership he's talked a
lot about leveling with the public about
the difficult decisions ahead so really
I guess this is your opportunity to do
that
should we be bracing ourselves for a
return to austerity well we Face very
difficult times as a country not least
because of Russia's legal invasion of
Ukraine and as we recover from covid and
at the heart of that the Prime Minister
and the chancellor Jeremy Hunt have put
restoring stability and that's
absolutely essential because for example
if we allow inflation to get out of
control mortgage rates to get out of
control everyone is going to suffer and
the poorest will suffer the worst so
it's right that we take difficult
decisions I have to say to to you and
your viewers there will be unfortunately
more significant difficult decisions to
come in the Autumn statement the week
after next but at the same time at the
heart of all of that as the Prime
Minister demonstrated during covid
compassion is at the heart of of what
he's doing and protecting the most
vulnerable and I think those are the
parameters of that Autumn statement it
is about difficult decisions but also
protecting the most vulnerable should
most of us expect to be paying more tax
well I think we're going to have to face
difficult decisions both on the the tax
side we haven't got to the end of the
difficult decisions there and difficult
decisions on the spending side now of
course in terms of the the specific
decisions that will be made that
conversation is ongoing between the the
Prime Minister and the chancellor and
you wouldn't expect any government
minister to comment before the the
Autumn statement I know you'll say you
can't comment Sunday Telegraph saying
the chancellor is looking at reducing
pension tax relief for higher earners is
that part of the discussion well so if
you you've you've been around these
events many times as I have been there's
an awful lot of speculation in in the
newspapers some of it's correct some of
it's not correct uh I can't go into any
individual uh stories but what I can say
is it is the case that will be difficult
decisions in that that Autumn statement
and previously with austerity we saw the
focus on spending cuts but it is right
it seems from what Youth and others have
said that actually tax Rises are going
to form a bigger part than previously
I I wouldn't I wouldn't say it's between
tax versus spending cuts we've got uh
unfortunately because of the difficult
decisions that we have to take we're
going to have to take difficult
decisions on both tax and spending but
of course as conservatives and I know
that the the Prime Minister and the
chancellor share this view with me we
need to Bear Down on spending first and
eliminate waste excessive spending and
only go to tax Rises if it's a last
resort but given the difficulty of the
public finances there is likely to be a
mix of the two and what can you give us
any you know what kind of that mix may
be 50 50. in favor it's not uh it's not
appropriate to get into the the detail
of that balance and indeed those
conversations are ongoing between the
premises we've been talking a lot about
tax cuts so far I just want to look a
little bit at spending because we went
to Bradford for the show this week a
correspondent a Fraser Maude Liz truss
of course promised to build Northern
Powerhouse Royal in full including a 43
billion pound High Speed Line Between
Leeds Liverpool and Bradford I just want
to play you what people were talking to
us about when we went to Bradford
I don't think it's gonna happen to get
from leads to Manchester takes over an
hour and costs more than 40 pounds of
return Journey it's impractical to not
have the two biggest most Financial
Centers in the north not linked together
by over an hour
do you think they're committed to
updating the north no they haven't got
no thoughts about that at all they're
not thinking oh so oh they don't pop
your bums and get up here and see what
they can do for us
University students talked a lot about
the Mandate from the 2019 election all
about leveling up all about leveling up
outside of London and you can see there
from Bradford people are really worried
you're going to go back on it well we're
committed to honoring our 2019 Manifesto
and leveling up forms the heart of it
and indeed that was a Manifesto that was
agreed uh by by the Prime Minister ended
by me and other members of the cabinet
with the Prime Minister we remain fully
uh committed to honoring our Manifesto
uh commitments however of course that is
in the context of a very difficult uh
financial situation but I can assure you
that the Autumn statement will continue
our commitment to to leveling up
including Northern Powerhouse rail in
full well it's it's tempting to get
drawn into each and every uh
announcement I've said that difficult
decisions will have to be taken but but
in taking those difficult decisions we
will be very cognizant of the duty that
we owe to people that voted to us for us
often for the first time in 2019 back to
Manifesto that included leveling up and
you will see leveling up being honored
in that manifest
no Russia is going to comp the climate
Summit in Egypt he's pledged to make the
UK a clean energy superpower he's also
talked about ending our dependence on
fossil fuels are you still planning to
issue more than 100 new drilling license
licenses for oil and gas in the north
city well I think it is the case that
when we Face a challenge with oil and
gas supply particularly after the
invasion of the Ukraine by Russia and
the effect that that's had on oil prices
and Global oil and gas supply we should
look to make sure that we continue to
provide oil and gas from our own
resources but that's not to say we're in
any way going soft on Renewables and
actually if you look at our records of
government since 2010 according to
different estimates we've been had
between a four and five-fold increase in
Renewables they're now about 40 percent
of our electricity Supply and we're
going to continue to press ahead with
that whether that's with huge investment
on offshore wind or or other measures
you say offshore wind
um but when it comes to onshore wind you
are making it much harder effectively
banning at new onshore uh wind and you
know if you're serious about climate
change you want to make the UK clean
energy superpower why are you running
back on onshore wind and drilling more
in the North Sea well we're not going
back on on Shore wind it has been the
case I think for about eight or ten
years that we made sure that local
residents views are properly taken into
account in respect of onshore wind
actually you can get huge amounts of
Renewables from offshore the UK has
become a global leader in offshore and
we've increased the Renewables as part
of the energy mix by about five foot
while we've been in government and I
think that's the right balance making
sure that we recognize local feelings
but at the same time investing in
Renewables now the stomach that's going
on in Egypt later on the program we are
going to be talking to the sister of
Allah adult who is a British Egyptian
human rights campaigner Defender he's
been held in jail on Hunger Strike his
sister is calling on the UK government
to try and do more to personally talk to
the Egyptian president to secure his
release and what can you tell us about
that case
well it's a very difficult case and it
has been raised by the UK government at
every level and I understand that the
foreign secretary raised it with his
Egyptian opposite number uh very
recently clearly I'm not going to get
into individual conversations that the
Prime Minister may have while he's at
the summit but I know the prime minister
is very much aware of it and will raise
it as appropriate okay I will be talking
to the sister later in the program to
get her reaction as well now
I'm interested to talk to you about your
role in government because you're in
charge of resilience planning which of
course with the winter approaching is
ever more important now the National
Grid has warned that there could be
blackouts if temperatures drop sharply
if Russia of course cuts off gas and oil
surprise uh to Europe have you been
wargaming at what to do if there are
these blackouts well I I leave the
cabinet's office which is in a way the
sort of HQ of government we we deal with
coordination across government and of
course we look at all different
scenarios it is going to be a a
challenging winter and of course we we
look at the situation in respect of
energy Supply I have to say that having
looked at and I know that
um my my colleague in in Bays Grant
chaps is is very much across this as
well we have got a robust resilience
plans and I would very much hope that we
would not find ourselves in the sort of
extreme situation that you describe you
obviously hope it doesn't happen but
what do those resilience plans look like
I mean there's been talk about National
Grid saying there could be three hour
blackouts between four to seven PM in a
worst case scenario it's accurate well
I'm not going to comment on individual
scenarios described what I would say
though is that uh the sort of Extreme
Measures that would see a lack of Supply
are are very much at the
uh that the the more unlikely scale of
these things happening so I I would say
to your viewers and and to you that uh
that certainly should not be their their
expectation of what would happen this
winter we do have uh robust resilience
plans in place
um another thing that we are perhaps
more likely to see uh is strikes almost
certain to see uh strikes uh in
different senses and there are reports
in The Observer Today that nurses have
voted to strike for the first time uh
nationally in their history what kind of
an impact could that have on the Health
Service well first of all we don't know
whether that that is the case and I very
much hope it doesn't turn out to be the
case we have well oiled contingencies in
place and the Department of Health is
across how we would deal with a scenario
like that should it arise and clearly
we'll make sure that we prioritized the
most essential Services emergency
services and so on but of course the the
would be an impact as a result of a
strike like that and I will continue to
urge nurses and others to to resist
going out on strike even if if they have
voted to do so I know these are
difficult times but but we have already
agreed quite considerable support for
nurses what would the impact be
well that would depend on the individual
hospitals and the scale of the adherence
to the strike but there are there are
well well all mechanisms in place to
make sure that we seek to minimize as
much as possible the the disruption to
to people particularly those in the the
most need but of course if you're in the
situation where you have
a large number of nurses going out on
strike of course that is going to have
an impact for example on some elective
surgery and other activities by
hospitals it's just inevitable given the
the numbers involved and of course the
NHS right now already are under pressure
I just want to have a look at the
current picture for a e waiting times
this is actually quite shocking when I
saw this graph I can actually really
believe it this is people who are
waiting 12 hours or more in a e and the
red line at the top is 2022
um September 32 776 people waited more
than 12 hours that's the highest number
in records going back to August 2010. I
mean this this is this looks like a you
know a Health Service that is really on
the brink here
yes we have very big challenges with the
Health Service
um it was only a year ago that we had a
global
um pandemic and you can see well if you
look at those numbers how that is
driving the the rise in pressure on uh a
d it's still coming up and and others
yes of course not now in 2022. well
first of all because
those those effects don't stop when the
pandemic the pandemic hasn't even
stopped but but as the the effects of
the pandemic Abate it is the case that
the backlogs continue to increase for
some time that is why the government is
investing record sums into the NHS and
the new health secretary Steve Barkley
is absolutely appraised of what we need
to do to make sure that we start to to
Bear down these numbers for example uh
just this week we've agreed an extra
half billion pounds 500 million pounds
worth of support to help through this
winter period to to address exactly this
sort of problems there's a complex range
of factors for example access to to GP
Services delayed discharges uh in
relation to to social care okay and I
know that the the health sector indeed
the Prime Minister have got a grip
across the board on this a quick thought
from you for your of course has been by
Rishi Sue next side during a roller
coaster uh year do you think that he
ever thought that he would have a second
chance
and I don't think he did and in a way I
don't think he would have wanted to have
had this situation where he came in in
such difficult times but I think he and
I and indeed the whole cabinet feel a
very profound sense of uh National Duty
and and getting on with the job of
dealing with the challenges that this
country faces and I can tell you that's
exactly what he's seized of every minute
of the day okay thank you very much
being on the program at Oliver Dowden
there
well there was Oliver downden uh talking
about a range of views including a cop
looking at the view from the labor party
now a shadow climate change and Net Zero
secretary Ed miliband joins us now from
Central London
and now before we get on to co-op and
climate change I just want your reaction
to the allegations around bullying and
Gavin Williamson uh we heard there
Oliver Dowden saying that Rishi sunak
still has full confidence in Gavin
Williamson that he was frustrated he
shouldn't have sent those messages but
that it was a long time ago
these are incredibly serious issues
Sophie and I think you know it really
calls into question Rishi sunak's
judgment and the way he made decisions
about his cabinet we already know about
the whole Suella bravaman issue being
reappointed six days after she resigned
it was very noticeable on your show that
Oliver Dowden couldn't deny that Rishi
sunak knew about those issues to do with
potential bullying against Wendy Morton
the chief whip by Gavin Williamson and
yet he reappointed him what it says is
that Rishi sunak was making decisions
simply in his own narrow short-term
interest as far as the conservative
party leadership was concerned not the
national interest and there needs to be
an urgent independent investigation to
exactly what happened we can't have a
cover-up we can't have a whitewash here
what did rishi's dunack know when did he
know it what did Gavin Williamson do and
and and what are the implications of
that
um is this kind of behavior normal I
guess in Parliament is what I'm trying
to get at you know is there a feeling
that you know it's a exceptional place
of work that people get frustrated as
Gavin Williamson's defense appears to be
or is this actually not normal at all
will it
let's be honest Sophie Parliament has
got a massive job to do to change our
culture I'm not denying to you that this
might have happened at some point over
the last few decades that this kind of
behavior
um but the point is we've got to change
parliament's got to change and the
example has got to be set from the top
and the point about this is that Rishi
sunak appears to have known that Gavin
Williamson was engaging in this Behavior
you know people in politics are
relatively tough the fact that Wendy
Morton was making a the former Chief
whip was making a complaint about this
suggests how extreme the behavior was
precisely as you say you know there's a
rough and tumble in politics but this
goes well beyond that apparently and it
really is a matter of judgment and the
basis on which Rishi sunak makes
decisions
and I also want to get your reaction to
your story in the Observer saying that
they believe that nurses will be voting
for their first ever National strike
action and some of our viewers were
concerned about the impact that's going
to have on an already stretched NHS do
you back the nurses in their strike
action
well look obviously nobody wants to see
a strike go ahead including nurses but
the truth is that this is born of
incredible frustration and dismay on the
part of nurses about what has happened
over 12 years under this government you
know labels in power for 13 years there
never was a nurse's strike what we've
seen is issues of pay issues of
recruitment issues of morale issues as
used showed to Oliver Dowden about what
is happening in the Health Service and
many nurses feel at breaking points so
nobody wants to see this strike go ahead
but as I say it is born of frustration
and distress that so many people feel in
the Health Service about the way it has
been run down over this last decade or
more under the Tories uh now I'm Keen to
talk to you a little bit about cop a big
climate change Summit that we're going
to be seeing in Egypt originally seen
like I said today he wants to see the UK
made a green energy superpower but of
course we know that the government is
they say a prioritizing offshore wind as
Oliver Darden was saying rather than
allowing new onshore wind farms to be
built do you have sympathy with people
who may not want to see onshore wind
near where they live
let me come to that let me start with
the big picture the big picture here
Sophie for the country in the world is
that the UN has told us that the
promises made in Glasgow haven't been
kept we're heading for 2.8 degrees of
global warming and obviously we're also
in the midst of a global energy crisis
now the message that labor would be
taking to cop27 and that I will be
taking at the end of this coming week
when I go is that it is now cheaper to
save the world than to destroy it what
do I mean by that I mean that Renewable
Power solar wind and other forms of zero
carbon energy are cheaper than fossil
fuels and this matters so much Sophie
because it means that at home and abroad
we need to be all in on those renewable
and zero carbon Alternatives now that
takes me to onshore wind it is terrible
what Oliver Downton was saying on your
program earlier he actually made some
important news by saying the government
was committing to carrying on with the
ban on onshore wind that has been in
place the last seven years for your
viewers at home Sophie that is driving
up their bills it's already driven up
but their bills by something like a
hundred pounds it will continue to drive
up their bills by 15 billion pounds
between now and 2030 if this ban remains
in place so the government is saying no
to the cheapest cleanest form of power
and by the way it's going back on a
promise that Jacob Reese mug made in the
brief period when he was the business
secretary where he said that they would
bring the consenting regime for onshore
wind in line with other infrastructure
it makes no sense and it makes a
complete joke frankly of Rishi sudak the
man who couldn't even decide whether he
was going to go to cop 27 it makes a
complete joke of the idea that he's
somehow a leader on clean energy
um he also said that
um they will be backing at some new
drilling licenses in the North Sea is an
important transition I guess and to
about energy security we will see what's
happening in Russia just to be very
clear will they oppose new drilling
licenses in the North Sea
well we do oppose them and let me
explain why the truth is and this goes
to the debate we've had about fracking
for example the truth is that wherever
we get our gas from we pay the same
price because the price is set on a
European market so this will make no
difference to bills firstly secondly it
will take years to come on stream this
is not cheap and it's not quick either
and thirdly it drives a coach and horses
through all the commitments we're making
on climate change because if every
country followed our lead we'd end up
with three degrees or more of global
warming precisely the danger that we are
seeking to avoid I agree with alok
Sharma the outgoing cop president on
this he said that he opposes what the
government is doing the answer the way
to cut bills the way to give us energy
security is onshore wind offshore wind
solar and labor has a world leading plan
to say by 2030 all of the all of the
power that the powers are elect system
will come from zero carbon sources
that's what we'd be taking to cop we'd
be saying to people come and be part of
our clean power Alliance so that
actually we can do the right thing on
bills and jobs and security and climate
I want to talk about that uh commitment
because as you say you've committed to
100 of the country's power being
provided by Renewables and nuclear by
2030. now that sounds great but I'm just
questioning whether it's achievable
looking at nuclear for example it takes
five to ten years to build nuclear power
station you've got to get planning
signed off Hinckley Point C was signed
off in 2016 not due to open until 2026.
I mean you've only got eight years to
meet your target two of them you're not
going to be in powerful I mean that's
not realistic is it
it it's stretching and it is absolutely
achievable and you know we had outside
experts issued a whole report on showing
how we would do this and let me explain
how we're going to do it it's going to
come from a combination of Renewable
Power absolutely crucial you know we're
going to double on Shore wind treble
solar quadruple offshore wind and that
is absolutely doable has been confirmed
by outside experts as I say nuclear we
have existing stations and we have
Hinckley coming online you're right that
new nuclear beyond that will be in the
2030s and also crucially something's
going to become more important so if
some of your viewers will be asking
about so-called intermittency of
Renewable Power like solar and wind
storage will play an increasing role so
yes it's stretching but we've got to do
it we can't afford not to do it you know
it's going to take 93 billion pounds off
bills between now and 2030 this
government and you know I think it shows
a labor party raring to go with the
solutions that this country needs on the
biggest you can face to that I mean
we'll be able to create the jobs that we
need sorry I'm I'm being told by your
own people that I need to speed up so
I'm doing you a favor I promise uh here
and Mr Miller oh I want to carry on I
want to carry I want you to carry on too
well okay we can then but just to
squeeze in one very final question we
know you're passionate about green
energy you drive an electric car if
you've got any guilty uneco-friendly
habits do you take too many long-haul
flights you partial to a stake anything
you want to get off your chest
I don't know look I'm not I think I
would say is I'm certainly not a parent
gonna virtue and I don't present myself
uh as that I try and do the right thing
and I think most people try and do the
right thing I just will make this point
though you see our vision quickly has
made this point our vision is of a
country that actually where people have
better lives as a result of the green
transition for example our GB energy our
publicly owned energy generation company
will create jobs and wealth in Britain
Sophie and so my my view on the green
agenda is and this is different from a
decade ago when I was climate change
secretary it's the ethical Choice it's
also the right economic choice the right
choice for quality of life so I think we
can improve people's quality of life as
we go green okay I've got to let you go
thank you very much for being on the
program today Mr miliband thank you
cheers cheers
well you're watching uh Sophie Richard
on Sunday it's been a busy morning
already from Gavin Williamson to com
we've got lots more to come on the
program as well because in just a moment
we're going to try and find out how
damaging climate change is already in
some of the most vulnerable places in
the world talking to the climate Envoy
from the Marshall Islands Tennessee plus
a little later this could be a bit of a
tone shift I'm going to warn you because
we're going to bring you a very powerful
interview with the labor MP for
Sheffield Central Paul blomfield now his
father took his own life we'll also be
getting some reaction from our political
interviews with our Deputy political
editor Sam coats who is standing by to
Manchester for us today he's going to be
telling us what the big takeaways are
from the interviews so far
[Music]
well let's turn back to cop down shall
we and the UN global climate change
conference is starting today as the UK's
presidency comes to an end and Egypt
takes over Rishi sunak will now fly to
shamal Sheikh as will Boris Johnson to
what's been called the African cop now
this time last year we spoke to the
climate Envoy of the Marshall Islands
it's a country that's already been
severely affected by a climate change
and today we are talking to Tennessee
again thank you so much for being with
us
today now the climate emergency is very
serious for you the Marshall Islands can
disappear in 50 years can you just
explain to us what the situation is
yes
um
you know sea levels are rising it's it's
already happening uh we've been impacted
by this crisis and we are already seeing
um
islets that have disappeared
we're having to think about where and
when people may need to move
to other Islands to Higher Ground which
by the way we don't have
so
it's very much front and center for us
and it's an existential it's an
existential issue we don't accept a
future in which we have no future
um and it's for that reason that you
know we're here at [ __ ]
um making the case and fighting for
our future
in our smaller countries like yourselves
are reliant really or larger wealthier
countries uh stumping up what's known as
adaptation funding to you know protect
you from climate change like the
flooding that we saw in some of these
images that were just on the screen and
you know last year you know cop in
Glasgow promised to double adaptation
funding but of course historically the
money has fallen well short of what's
been promised have you got any faith
that things might be different this year
thank you we need this process to
deliver
the Marshall Islands obviously
uh needs it to deliver us immediately
we really have no time to lose in terms
of getting started on the adaptation
planning that we're already engaged in
you know we're already having to look at
very difficult decisions on
where people might have to go and what
the future looks like so we're already
doing the work
we chair the high ambition Coalition
when a very big part of that decision at
Glasgow last year that came from
developed countries in terms of telling
our story and having people understand
the gravity of the issue and we were so
happy when we developed countries came
forward with that commitment on doubling
of adaptation Finance but what we need
now is delivery we need to see that when
promises are made and pledges are made
those promises are kept and those
pledges are delivered on and that is
what builds uh trust in this process
that is what leads to success and every
cop
needs to be a success
um for for the entire world
that's the key point isn't it you know
in some ways the commitment to the easy
bit it's the delivery that is difficult
do you sometimes think that these
Summits are a bit like a PR exercise I
guess for some world leaders you know
they construct the stage they can talk
the talk on climate change but then
actually it ends with promises that are
broken
it can't be a PR exercise I wouldn't be
here if I thought that that's all this
that all that's all this was
you know
um the cops have produced some real and
significant progress uh the commitment
to 1.5
um is there because we've engaged in
this process the recognition that
adaptation needs are significant and
need more financing that happened
because we engage in this process
um the signal to the world that in fact
uh Renewables are
the basis for a secure and safe future
for all of us that happens because of
this process the process
is what we have and it could be a lot
better I'm not trying to say that it is
you know
what we need in fact we need much more
action that is accelerated and we're in
an incremental process but it is a
process that gives countries like mine
that are small and that are on the front
of the front lines of voice
and let's face it if um there wasn't a
cop I wouldn't be sitting here right now
talking to you and explaining how
important
um this is and how important it is that
the the world as a as a whole respond to
what is a global crisis in a global
manner
um and so you know
we show up we show up every year it is
not a PR exercise for us and it
shouldn't be a PR exercise for anyone
else
I'm interested to know what it's like at
negotiating the final deals and in
places like Corp you know we just we're
looking at pictures there with John
Kerry you know surrounded by delegates
right at the 11th Hour hashing out last
minute trade-offs
um what is it like in the negotiating
room to smaller countries like yours
have a voice
um it's intense uh
um and it's it's exhausting there isn't
a lot of sleep in this process uh
uh this is my first week
um we're going to be here for another
two weeks uh you know ask me what it's
like at the very end
um you really do put all of your energy
um your heart
um everything that you believe in into
it and
uh it's extremely intense
um but as I said before we're fully
committed to finding Solutions through
this process and we're continuing we'll
we'll continue to show up
okay thank you so much for being on the
program today very busy uh week ahead
for you thank you
thank you so much
now as usual the take is going to follow
this program just after 9 30. it's our
chance to analyze today's interviews
talk through any news lines as well
without Deputy political editor at Sam
coats but we can get a quick take from
Sam now on what stood out from him so
far this morning he's in Manchester
today morning Sam and what has your main
takeaway been from the show so far then
so that you covered a huge array of
challenges for if you see that the Prime
Minister but the most urgent newsline
from the show this morning is that the
prime minister is standing by Gavin
Williamson after Sunday Times published
those exclusive written messages from
the now cabinet office Minister uh who
was a just a few weeks ago a back
venture to the then Chief whip Wendy
Morton Oliver Dowden a very close Ally
of the Prime Minister said that it's
right to move on it was a very difficult
time he suggested that quite a lot of
people had a difficult relationship with
Wendy Morton and suggests that while
Gavin Williamson now regrets what he
said there will be no further action
from the Prime Minister about Gavin
Williamson's future he left just a
glimmer uh for further action if they
changed their mind saying there is a
conservative investigation a party
investigation into him going on but for
now Gavin Williamson stays in post
Oliver Dowden saying that barely half an
hour ago on your show thanks very much
Sam we'll have more from you of course
at 9 30. uh yes Sam there at
highlighting what I thought actually was
quite a storage defense of Gavin
Williamson by Oliver dardan this morning
now 11 years ago Paul blomfield who is
the labor MP for Sheffield Central was
in Parliament when he got a phone call
he was told in that call that his father
had died now his dad was 87 he had
terminal lung cancer but he'd taken his
own life and since then Paul's been
campaigning for a change in the law to
allow a sister dying helping someone to
take their own life is currently illegal
and punishable with up to 14 years in
jail that's under the suicide Act of
1961. Now new polling by dignity and
dying which campaigns for a change in
the law does show there is support for
Parliament to debate the issue before we
hear from Paul there is a warning that
his interview discusses suicide some
viewers may find it upsetting I
certainly did when I spoke to him
what is the current law when it comes to
assisted dying
well essentially it's illegal the
current law
prevents people having choice at the end
of their life
and it drives people to take very
desperate measures in many cases like my
father did
and also those around them if it's seen
that anyone's assisted someone in taking
it yes even
discussing their plans would make family
members complicit and of course some
people have been prosecuted for that and
what do you want to happen
I want to see a change in the law which
gives people choice
which means that for people who have a
terminal diagnosis
of six months or less and know the end
is certain
that they can choose the point
at which they pass instead of in many
cases having to live out a fairly
miserable death
now you mentioned your father and of
course earlier you gave a very moving
speech in the House of Commons about him
and about how he chose to take his own
life I think it was exactly eight years
after you received a phone call in
Westminster to say that he had died that
you gave the speech he was 87. what was
your father called
Harry Harry he sounds like a really
extraordinary person from what you were
saying you know you talked about him
having quite a tough upbringing in in
the East End of London yeah he was he
was brought up in poverty
the war changed it for him
because he became an RF pilot
and uh that opened up opportunities I
mean he was offered a job as an airline
pilot but he turned it down because he
thought there was no future in
commercial Aviation I love that he built
a very successful business career
and he had a good life and he enjoyed it
yeah you said I think in the speech that
he was someone who made the most of his
life absolutely what kind of person was
he well he was a great father he's very
private person but
even so I think he would
want me to talk about
his death because I know he always
believed in giving people choice
and in a sense that should have given me
an indication
of what he might do after he had a
terminal diagnosis but
I didn't really factor in
what what kind of things did he say to
them
well he was quite positive
um even after after his diagnosis and
was trying to make the most of things
um
and so it was a real shock
to get a call out to the blue
to say being found dead in his garage
you you said that he had a terminal
diagnosis
and it was inoperable lung cancer he was
yeah was that out of the blue or was it
something that was expected
um
he'd only talked to me about the
diagnosis a couple of months earlier
he'd spent the short spell in hospital
and I don't know how long because he was
such a private person I don't know how
long
um he'd actually been suffering he'd had
kind of respiratory issues but
um there was a time at which he was a
heavy smoker
um
so the actual
diagnosis I think was a shock for him
and it was for us and you say you know
he's someone who sees Life by the sound
of it as well so someone yeah he'd had
his share of health problems he'd been
diabetic for many years
just cope with them all
and you were in Westminster when you
found out news of his death it was a
phone call was it yeah
what were you doing at the time do you
remember
I think I was walking between meetings
yeah and it was a phone call from his
partner
I mean it must have been very
it was really hard
obviously I got in training straight
back too straight back to Sheffield
and you said that you had spoken to him
the night before as well
yeah as it happened
um I've been down it was uh
on the Sunday evening and was walking
into Chambers Park
um
and we we had a perfectly ordinary
conversation
um it's such a difficult I just want to
say thank you for talking to us about
her I completely recognize how difficult
it is if there's any point you want to
take a breather or take a glass of water
and just just do that okay
um
you said at the beginning of the
interview
is that because of the laws around a
sister dying people can't talk about
anything with their loved ones whether
it's yourself or whether it's people's
Partners you know is that something that
you feel strongly about I guess after
what happened with your father well
really strongly in this point I made in
more than one debate in the
Commons that a lot of the discussion
around assisted dying is focused on
what would the terrain look like if we
changed the law and I think we need to
give much more attention
to what the law already does to people
and the misery that it causes
so not changing the law is a
Act of
deep harm for many people
and if obviously I know you want to
speak for yourself but so it's
completely fine if you don't want to
answer this question
did his partner know about it either I
guess and that must have been difficult
for them as well
yeah I mean the point that I made is so
so you know if the law had been
different
as it is in other countries as it's soon
going to be in Scotland probably judging
by the moon there
um he could have talked to us
we'd have planned together
he would probably have lived longer
I think he took the decision
to go prematurely
because he wanted to act well he still
could
and
if you've been able to talk we could
plan together
he'd have lived longer
and being able to die with his family
around him
no not at all thank you for showing the
story it's so important
sorry take a moment
no no not at all just Tate wants to take
as long as you can it's incredibly
powerful and it is I think the point
that you make about how there's a
situation that we need to look at the
situation now is really important like
you know you talk a lot about the risks
and the downfalls of
if you change the law but you say like
not acting is also a decision
you you say that they're already looking
at changing the law in Scotland
um
what kind of thing is happening there
and would you like the same thing to be
happening in England as well well I mean
Scotland is following New Zealand
states in the in the US and others
who've recognized that giving people
choice is a Humane and sensible thing to
do
and Scotland's moving down the road and
it's along the lines that we would be
seeking in England to say that once
people had had that terminal diagnosis
so that their M was inevitable it was
just a question of
how and when
they should be given that choice
and you know sometimes people will say
well all we need is decent palliative
care
ironically I mean it was and that's
absolutely right we should improve
palliative care
but
my father took his decision
shortly after
uh ironically enough he'd met the
MacMillan nurse and she talked about
what the end might look like
and
at 87
he'd seen a lot of his friends die
and sometimes were badly you know there
is this myth about palliative care
that people involvement do a fantastic
job
but
it doesn't mean
going gently into the sunset
um in the way that it's sometimes
portrayed with the very best palliative
care
many people have very bad deaths
and I think as my father thought I
should make your choice over whether
they wanted that
or they could go at their own time with
their own choosing
that's one of the arguments the
palliative care argument another
argument I guess um is that people worry
that if a sister dying becomes legal
then some people could be taken
advantage of that it's a slippery slope
that people who perhaps worry that they
might be a burden to their loved ones
could be encouraged to do something that
they may not really want to do
I think those who oppose assisted dying
struggle to find reasons and that's
clearly one of the reasons that's put
forward I find it
in in my circumstances my experience
I find it quite offensive because
I think most people want their love and
still live longer yeah of course
the
you know my father would have lived
longer
if he'd had choice
um the pressure that he felt
was to
take his life while he could
well he still had the choice well he
still had the capacity
because he'd seen friends
die badly without that opportunity to
act when they
realized they wanted to
um so I think
the argument is actually you can turn
the argument on its head
changing the law
will let people live longer
and
I don't see
families
using a change in the law to press
people
to go sooner
do you have any sense about what the
attitude is in Westminster towards the
sister dying or potential change
well westminster's behind the curve I
think things are changing
um over the 12 years I've been in
Parliament I think the balance is
Shifting there is more support but we
are still well behind the General Public
um the latest polling that I've seen has
something like 81 percent of people
supporting a change in the law to enable
assisted dying and that's almost
identical between supporters of the two
main parties
so partner needs to go quite some way to
catch up with public opinion
personally I think it's only a question
of time
but the issue is
how many people are going to suffer
needlessly
until Palmer gets his act together and
changes the law in line with public
opinion
uh just finally at the beginning you
were talking about people who have only
have a certain amount of time left to
live do you think that is an important
um I guess like control on it
just think that
now this is a
difficult area of law but frankly
that's what Palm it's for we do
difficult though
um but I think that it's a kind of
sensible
and balanced approach
to say six months
to live with the terminal diagnosis and
uh validate that's kind of confirmed by
uh doctors is is a secure way of dealing
with the issue
and that's what most people support
so what would your message be to you
know the health secretary then
well I hope that um
the new health secretary will look
afresh at the issue
um
previous
debate has kind of got us to a point
where it looked as if the government
were going to open up discussion and
then it's pulled back
um I think that we just need an open
debate which gathers evidence
looks at people's experience
and enables us to find time empowerment
to look at the issue properly which
we've never done
thank you very much
it's been a pleasure talking to you
well that was the labor and P for
Sheffield Central Paul Bromfield talking
about his father
now support is available from the
Samaritans day or night 365 days a year
so you can corn them for free that's on
116 one two three you can also email
them at Joe
samaritans.org or you can also visit
www.samaritans.org to find your nearest
branch
now we did ask the government for
comments on the campaign for a change in
the law and the Minister of Justice said
our sympathies remain with the families
and loved ones affected by these deeply
upsetting cases any change to the law in
an area of such sensitivity and
importance is for individual MPS to
consider rather than a decision for
government
now of course assessor dying is a very
contentious subject and important to say
that later today on Sky News there will
also be an interview with an
organization that opposes a change in
the law that's called care not killing
that's at 1 30 pm on Sky News
is a British Egyptian democracy activist
and writer who's been in prison for
Egypt for most of the last decade in
December last year he was jailed for a
further five years for supposedly
spreading fake news he's been on Hunger
Strike but from today he says he will
refuse to drink water as well the
foreign secretary James cleverley says
the government is working tirelessly for
his release but his family's warning
that he could die even during Rishi
sunak's visit to the country for cop and
now we can reveal on this program that
prime minister Rishi sunak has written
to his sister Sana saying that he is
committed to seeking Allah's release
Santa will be flying to Egypt later
today but she joins us now at live on
the program thank you so much for being
with us it must be you know very
distressing time for you and your family
when was the last time you heard from
your brother it was um on the on the
31st so like
a week ago through a letter
uh where he told us that he will
escalate his hunger strike last time
anyone saw him was my mom on on the 16th
we only have a visit once a month it's
behind the glass Shield
um and so the next visit will be on the
16th which would be too late I think
and talked he's been on hunger strike
for before eating just 100 calories a
day for seven months I'm like I can't
imagine what that must have been like
yeah he's uh he's been on this partial
hunger strike for over 200 days
I last saw him in August that's the last
time I visited Egypt and he already
looked very very freely already looked
to me very scary
um his eyes were sunken he he looked
strange
um his mind was still alert and he was
still like my brother but
I I was reading online about what
happens when you're dehydrated what
happens to a body when
you stop water and it's it's already
very scary for a normal body and Alice
but he's not normal he's very free
already
I just want to also remind that he is
he's putting his body on on the line not
because he wants to die but because he
wants to live and he wants his life back
and he's really tired of this
Alia has a a 10 year old boy and I spent
nine of the past nine in the past nine
years in prison he he hasn't had time
with his kid
we're having a look at and
him
you two together on the screen behind us
at now very different yeah we're looking
brother I'm sure at this point oh he
doesn't look like that at all we were in
South Africa having a safari back then
um he has been in prison as you say for
the best part of a decade and he was
sentenced for five years imprisonment in
Egypt last December can you just explain
to us why he's in prison
technically for like
Facebook posts the only piece of
evidence there's a Facebook post that he
shared not one that you wrote but one
that you shared about a human rights
violation in Egyptian prison
um but Allah is also and it is like Ali
is a writer and he was a prominent uh
pro-democracy secular activist figure
back in 2011 whether when there was a an
uprising in Egypt and so he's kind of
used to set an example for others
um and that's why I think the attack is
so vicious on him that's why they're
keen on keeping him in prison and
whenever he finishes the sentence they
put him on a new one
was saying his boy there as well
the rare occasions that he could see his
dad
has not seen his father for over a year
now
because Khaled is um he's non-verbal he
does not communicate he's on the
Spectrum
and for the past three years Alex visits
are behind the glass shield with phone
speakers we've explained many times to
the Egyptian authorities that his son
cannot communicate in that form
at first they would make like exceptions
for the kid and then they decided not to
um so that's I'm I'm stressing on these
things because Alias denied many of his
basic rights even by their laws which
are wrong his his charge on a
misdemeanor but they treat him as if
he's like a a terrorist or a grand
Criminal and of course this is happening
in Egypt which is preparing to host
world leaders for the cop climate change
Summit you've received a letter from
Russia students the UK prime minister
what does it say
um I was glad to see that he he said
we received it yesterday that he said
that he he feels our
our family is paid that is he
understands this painful time for the
family
um I
it's good that we have a commitment from
the prime minister's office but what
worried me is that he said that we will
get information after the conference
I feel like
the Prime Minister needs to understand
the urgency after the conferencing could
be too late
I I know it's not the prime minister's
uh
mistake but
the foreign office the embassy and
we've we've been we've been they've been
working on this for for very long and I
feel like they've been setting the prime
minister to fail in this trip it will be
his first trip
and so it's it's a challenge but I I
hope I hope prime minister Rishi sunak
understands the urgency and I know he
can do it if he has his mind to it and
if he shows the rest of the entities in
the government that this is a priority
and I know it's really hard to to talk
about but just to I guess make it really
Crystal Clear what you're saying is
you're saying that it could be too late
because your brother is about to stop
drinking water and he could he could die
while cop is going on is that what you
what you mean yeah I'm worried that he
could die while the conference is
happening and while the prime minister
is over there
I'm I'm also we don't have a way to know
so I I would urge the Prime Minister and
the British government to be the ones
responsible for getting us Proof of Life
and consider access is a right to the
British government we as family
our first visit is on the 16th my mom
will go every other day to the prison
and try to to ask but
they can ignore her so while there is a
British delegation that will be over
over there an official delegation that
will be engaging with the Egyptian
authorities
the Egyptians need to show some respect
to the prime minister's visit and
get Consular access to the Embassy or
get us a proof of life until it is
resolved it's it's very urgent and
as Naomi Klein put it in in an article
she said if
if we can't save this man if we can't
get him out of prison not hope do we
have for saving our planet this this
case has got so much International
attention and solidarity
and all of these world leaders are going
including prime minister Rishi sunak
this is a very they will make big
pledges about the planet that we're not
sure if they will work or not according
to so the previous conferences but this
is a very simple thing that you can make
happen and it's a good thing and it's
just it's not that hard
and in the letter which is like does say
that he is going to raise this directly
with the Egyptian president is that
something that gives you some optimism I
understand what you're saying about time
frame of course it gives me optimism
that he sent the family a letter and
that he understands the urgency but just
raising it I don't know like it has been
raised before and I feel like
politicians understand when when they
raise things out of lip service or when
they actually care
um and and I'm sure I'm sure number 10
understands how to do how to do it
properly so I'm I'm hoping it won't be
just lip service I'm hoping it will be
we really care
um Britain has a very strong
relationship with Egypt and and so it's
easy it's your friend you can
negotiate something with them okay
okay you're so much for being on the
program I know how difficult it has been
for you to to talk about this that we
you know admire your bravery in coming
on and being a voice of your brother
thank you thank you thank you
well that is it for this week's Sophie
bridge on Sunday in a moment after the
break we're going to be running through
today's interviews and having a look at
what we learned with our Deputy
political editor Sam coats thanks as
always for joining us this Sunday
morning
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's interviews with some analysis from
our Deputy political editor Sam Coates
who joins us now live in Manchester for
us uh this morning
so I feel quite um I guess emotionally
drained after that program there's a
couple of interviews at the end uh that
were um you know a bit away from the
usual sort of rougher tumble of
Westminster most notably with Paul
Bonfield the labor MP who spoke about
his father and taking his own life and
he was 87 years old with an incurable
cancer diagnosis
and it was about her sister dying and
I'll be honest it was probably one of
the most you know emotional interviews I
can really remember doing ever I'll be
honest and it was a very intense he
spoke very eloquently about it
um what is the feeling in Westminster
that's right Sophie I mean watching that
normally we would dive straight in early
Burley of Westminster politics but after
that interview you did just want to sort
of pause and reflect and pick up on some
of the some of the themes Paul blomfield
who by the way is a sort of Shadow
Minister on the labor front bench you
might not necessarily have come across
him before but but that was just an
extraordinary uh interview there talked
in it about how he felt essentially
Westminster was behind the curse let's
just hit that bit of the interview again
and then pick up on what he was talking
about
changing the law
will let people live longer
and
I don't see
families
using a change in the law to press
people
to go sooner
do you have any sense about what the
attitude is in Westminster towards the
sister dying or potential change a
little
well westminster's behind the curve I
think things are changing
over the 12 years I've been in
Parliament I think the balance is
Shifting there is more support but we
are still well behind the general public
the latest polling that I've seen has
something like 81 percent of people
supporting a change in the law to enable
assisted dying
and that's almost identical between
supporters of the two main parties
so apartment needs to go quite some way
to catch up with public opinion
personally I think it's only a question
of time
um but the issue is
how many people are going to suffer
needlessly
until Palmer gets his act together and
changes the law in line with public
opinion
I mean it's important to say isn't it
sound that you know this is a subject
that brings strong emotions and people
on both sides of the debate and people
feel very strongly and passionately and
rightly it's an area of law that's very
important to get right and where do you
think the current debate is in
Westminster
well I think first of all it's important
to say that we're not facing an imminent
vote on this as far as we can tell
there's a lot on the political agenda
just after that interview I was just
interrogating the views of the most
senior politicians in the country now
this was last tested in Parliament in
2015 uh in a vote on assisted dying
Richie sunak didn't take part in that
vote Dominic Rob Deputy Prime Minister
and for the purposes of this debate uh
the uh justice secretary also didn't
take part in that vote and Steve Barkley
who's the health secretary who would
also uh play a role in any discussion
that actually voted against assistive
dying in in that vote
um so that gives you a sense of where
some at the top of government I know it
would be a free vote a conscience issue
there wouldn't be party whips involved
but people do look to the principles but
but if you look over the other side of
the aisle uh kirst armor who of course
had to deal with these cases as director
of public prosecutions while he gave an
interview about assist to dying in 2015
in which he said he wouldn't stand in
the way of change if it came because he
had experience in this area so that
gives you a sense that perhaps the
leadership on the labor side a little
bit more open to it I think just at the
moment there's a little political
Headroom uh on the government benches to
to deal with this but it is as uh Paul
was saying to you uh an issue in which
sometimes it can look as if the polling
suggests that the public are a little
bit ahead of Westminster uh really
interesting uh Sam important to say that
we are going to be hearing from someone
on the other side of the debate later on
at Sky News at 1 30 uh today
um now we also on the program spoke to
the chancellor at the Dutch of Lancaster
Oliver Dowden someone who's very close
to Rishi sunak about those bullying
claims against the cabinet office
Minister sir Gavin Williamson now before
we get Sam's take I asked Mr Dowden if
Mr Williamson still enjoys the
confidence of the Prime Minister
these were sent In the Heat of the
Moment uh expressing frustration uh it
was a difficult time for the party I
think he now accepts that he shouldn't
have done it and he regrets doing so and
I think that that's right and thankfully
we're in a bit of a better place now as
a party
it sounds a bit threatening there
doesn't it there's a price for
everything what's that supposed to mean
well remember this was uh Gavin winners
and when he was a backbencher expressing
his frustrations at a difficult time for
the party with the then Chief whip he
regrets the language that he uses and I
don't think he should have used that
that sort of language but nonetheless
that that is in the past now and now
thankfully we're in a better place as a
party it's not very long ago it's not
like it was three years ago it was just
a you know a matter of kind of weeks ago
if you like and also you know most
people would look at this and say okay
everyone gets frustrated at work most
people wouldn't send those kind of
messages to a colleague does British
have confidence in him well he shouldn't
have sent those messages and he says
that he regrets it but of course the the
Prime Minister continues to have
confidence in Gavin Williamson as a
minister
well that was Oliver Darden uh with
these interviews I never really know
particularly if it's a breaking story
how strongly or not someone's going to
row in behind Gavin Williamson and I
have to say I thought that was quite a
strong defense of Gavin Williamson by
Oliver dad and clearly uh the view is
from number 10 that they are rowing in
behind him at least uh for now now that
hasn't necessarily gone down well with
everyone just to bring you a tweet from
Nadine Doris and of course a former
cabinet secretary under Boris Johnson
she said Oliver Dowden stated that
Williamson's Behavior was excusable
because he had a difficult relationship
with Wendy Morton any woman would have
had the same with any man who tried to
bully threaten and intimidate her Oliver
dowden's casual defense of Williamson is
just wrong and totally indefensible so
that was Nadine Doris's interview to uh
a reaction to our interview with Oliver
Darden well let's bring Sam back in uh
shall we
and it was pretty first of all what did
you make of the Oliver down in defense
well I thought it revealed a couple of
very interesting things first of all I
mean he just bluntly revealed to you
that darling streets are standing by
Gavin Williamson and and I think that it
would actually be quite hard for
Richardson that to do anything else
given that even if he hadn't seen the
exact detail uh of those texts the line
by line that the Sunday Times put in the
public domain late last night then they
had to concede that he was notified that
there was an issue here between Gavin
Williamson and and Wendy Morton and so a
bit like with the Zoella breatherman
case the problem is that if Richard Cena
took action now actually it would raise
a lot of questions about why he'd
appointed Gavin Williamson in the first
place so to sack him this morning would
simply to raise the question why did he
appoint him uh a couple of weeks ago
anyway so I think I I think that was
quite quite striking but but it but in
the way that Oliver Dalton talked about
it you just you just saw a little bit of
the much much bigger tensions below the
surface here because
Oliver Delton sought to present Wendy
Morton is quite a divisive figure he
said that a lot of people had a
difficult uh relationship with uh her
and that and that's just observable fact
it was a very grumpy conservative party
when Wendy Morton was Liz truss's Chief
whip kind of culminating in that final
24 hours before this just had to leave
power with those scenes uh in the voting
lobbies of the House of Commons which if
nothing else uh were extraordinarily
grumpy
um and and as Nadine dory's tweet
touches on those wounds within the
conservative party haven't healed there
are fishes there are there are there are
sort of open sores all over the place
and it only takes an incident like this
to sort of to pick the scab off to to
make it all raw again and and that is
just one of the big dangers for Richie
see that
uh yeah certainly it does expose at
those divisions so it doesn't sound
thanks very much we'll have more from
Sam in just a few uh moments so where
we're going to be talking uh about the
uh climate issue as well plus the
economic challenges ahead it was a
pretty busy wide-ranging show this
morning wasn't it see in a moment
[Music]
I think it's very important because I
think in particular in in our industry
is where I learned a lot about kind of
men not having the ability to show their
vulnerable side I think
um in the footballing world I'm sure
Hugo will talk about kind of like life
as a rugby player but we was always kind
of brought up with words like man up get
on with it you know just uh go out there
and play and if I'd walked into any
dressing room with a hamstring injury or
I don't know with a calf tear you know
the physio would do all that all that
they can to put you back together to
kind of get out there and play on a
Saturday afternoon but if I think if I'd
have gone into training will I know if
I'd have gone into training and said
look
I'm feeling down I'm feeling anxious I
was crying last night I don't know why
all of these words would have just kind
of rang alarm Bells I think to managers
and uh and staff during that particular
time because of or maybe their lack of
knowledge or their lack of awareness to
talk about this subject and that they
would have just said look get out there
and get on with it I think when I look
at my career where I started back in
2001 to where we are now it's good to
see the progression of that but the
perception the reality of rugby and
rugby players in general are because
it's a combat Sport and there's a sense
of warfare and it's really physical that
you were just physically robust none of
that actually correlates to the mental
aptitude or the resilience of Any Given
person Jermaine's absolutely spot on a
hamstring injury a bicep tear any of
those physical injuries are easy to
detect you can scan them MRIs all those
kind of things but when there is a
mental Frailty because it is this
invisible problem or issue it's hard to
detect and therefore it becomes hard to
qualify and it's harder to talk about
and you also don't want to weaponize
people who are essentially employing you
so me saying to a coach
I'm feeling under it mentally I don't
think I'm quite stable well I don't want
that to be used against me in team
selection contract renewals all the rest
of it so we really want to break down
these stigmas where my career finished
so abruptly at the age of 31 and it was
like you're never going to play football
again that's when I kind of hit a point
where I had to start speaking to
somebody because I had nowhere else to
go I was in a really dark place
um family and friends around that
particular time if I didn't have them I
don't know what might have happened I
was I was really lost and thankfully
they started to kind of build some
really simple mechanisms in my life just
to kind of piece me back together
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome back to safer Ridge on
Sunday the take where we take you back
through the morning's interviews with
some analysis as well we've talked a lot
about Westminster Intrigue I guess so
far you know the Gavin Williamson story
but really at the big big issue that is
going to be impacting all of us is what
on Earth the government is going to do
when it comes to the economy just 11
days until we get that Autumn statement
and I asked Oliver Dowden who is as
close to Richie sunac as you can get if
we should brace for a return to
austerity
I have to say to to you and your viewers
there will be unfortunately more
significant difficult decisions to come
in the Autumn statement the week after
next but at the same time at the heart
of all of that as the Prime Minister
demonstrated during covid compassion is
at the heart of of what he's doing and
protecting the most vulnerable and I
think those are the parameters of that
Autumn statement it is about difficult
decisions but also protecting the most
vulnerable well I'm not going to comment
on individual scenarios described what I
would say though is that uh the sort of
Extreme Measures that would see a lack
of Supply are are very much at the
uh the the more unlikely scale of these
things happening so I I would say to
your viewers and and to you that uh that
certainly should not be their their
expectation of what would happen this
winter we have well oiled contingencies
in place and the Department of Health is
across how we would deal with a scenario
like that should it arise and clear you
would make sure that we prioritized uh
the most essential Services emergency
services and so on but of course the the
would be an impact as a result of a
strike like that and I will continue to
urge nurses and others to to resist
going out on strike even if they have
voted to do so I know these are
difficult times but but we have already
agreed quite considerable support for
nurses
oh well quite a lot of different parts
of the Oliver Darden interview uh
squeezed together there but the one I'm
quite Keen to talk about is at the
beginning when he's talking about the
potential return to austerity and the
balance between spending cuts and tax
Rises let's bring in adaptive political
editor uh Sam coats um there was a bit
of pitch rolling from Oliver dad and
that we've seen of course from the
chancellor and the Prime Minister as
well
um but I guess do you think we are
potentially going to be seeing a
different form of you know austerity if
you like from this government with more
of an emphasis on tax cuts than we've
seen before I mean tax Rises I should
say
um it does seem like that if you if you
wind back to 2010 where we had as it
were austerity 1.0 with George Osborne
that was done on a more or less 80 20
ratio uh well that was the aspiration at
the time anyway 80 spending cuts 20 tax
Rises and I I mean the suggestion of how
they're going to fill the probably
around 50 billion maybe a bit more black
hole is that it'll be 50 spending cuts
50 tax Rises that that that's a sort of
suggestion that's not formally confirmed
by government and Oliver Daven wouldn't
uh wouldn't wouldn't say anything about
that but but clearly I think that tax
Rises are going to play part a bigger
part of that mix and I think
um that you do have quite a lot of that
falling on corporate shelters I mean it
might um it might end up being that
energy companies that they're getting
huge windfalls from the current
situation between the war in Ukraine
higher prices and higher profits
actually face quite a lot of the the
bill but but there's no doubt that we're
that we're all going to uh we're all
going to find it very challenging that
the most interesting thing though this
morning safely is we've been hearing for
some days ministers as you say Patrol
prepare us uh for what's going to come
in 11 days time and we're just starting
to see a little bit of dissent in the
Tory bat benches about this there's an
article today from Ian Duncan Smith in
the sun on Sunday where he starts to
warn against tax risers saying we can't
look here in the conservative party like
we're just an extension of the labor
party and then he goes on to say you
know that the black hole that we're all
talking about might not actually be so
big or even exist after all he's talking
about maybe uh the easing situation on
energy meaning uh that the cost of that
intervention is lower and so the black
hole isn't as big but if you get
grumbling on the Tory back benches about
the central bit of of um
since he's gone some time ago of Richie
sunax uh fiscal plan uh then we really
are in trouble Rishi connect one shot at
a successful Premiership is to bring the
conservative party behind what will
undoubtedly be a very difficult set of
decisions if the party collectively
decides that he's aimed too high cut too
hard raise taxes too much given all of
the discussion that we had over the
summer that led to the election of Liz
trust because taxes were too high then I
think he's got problems on his back
benches and and things could actually
unravel quite a bit so managing his
party as well as the country I think is
a very difficult moment but but what
that brief Montage of bits of the show
did was it brought together it's not
just austerity 2.0 that's the challenge
you've got the potential for blackouts
which Oliver Darwin was was playing down
but but not ruling out and then the
prospects of strikes because there's not
much money for public sector pay just
just look at that entire landscape
Sophie it is so difficult Richard Cena
has come in to number 10 and in many
senses he's calmed down the atmosphere
he's trying to to project stability and
strength after the chaos of the last few
weeks but just the sheer facts of what
he's confronting with all of those
issues including the biggest spending
cuts since 2010 at a time where there's
so little fat I mean it it you know
don't underestimate this isn't politics
Going Quiet for the next few weeks and
months this is really really difficult
stuff that because of the tensions we
were talking about earlier in the show
really could unravel on the six months
Oliver Daven said that Richard Cena
didn't want to return didn't think he'd
return and didn't want to return in
these circumstances but his sense of
Duty means that he and his top team feel
that they must
yes I think that's right I think it is
going to be incredibly difficult perhaps
nobody would want to confront the
challenges that Richard Cena has in his
intro right now so I'm going to forgive
you for modeling up Boris Johnson and
Richie Cena given the turnover and prime
ministers that we've seen in the last
couple of months
do you think just a very quick thought
because we haven't got long last do you
think things are slowing down or do you
think that actually come that Autumn
statement it is going to ramp straight
back up again
depends whether Rich you see that can
Jeremy Hunt get it right if that looks
like it's unraveling all hell could
break these uh there you go uh Sam uh
let's hope that isn't a premonition uh
Sam thank you as always for being on the
program do check out the safety bridge
on Sunday at podcast as well as with
myself at political correspondent Liz
Bates plus uh show editor Scott Beasley
we're going to be going back through
that Oliver Dowden interview plus the
one on Paul blomfield you don't want to
miss that one that is it from safe
origin Sunday the take out this morning
uh good to have you with us this Sunday
morning see you on Wednesday 9pm for
Sophie Ridge
foreign
[Music]